[Musica]
siamo a Milano nel 1926 nell'inverno del
1926 e Vittoria è un formentano che era
un giovane ematologo viene chiamato al
capezzale di una donna che ha appena
partorito
questa donna ha avuto delle complicanze
dopo il parto e Vittorio che è un bravo
medico avrebbe potuto salvarla Ma poiché
serviva il sangue e il sangue non c'era
quella donna è morta
e Vittorio ci pensa e ci ripensa torna a
casa la sera e non riesce a dormire
perché gli sembra veramente ingiusto è
quell'indignazione sana no di fronte una
morte ingiusta che anche oggi abbiamo
davanti agli occhi per la guerra per i
cambiamenti climatici ne abbiamo parlato
prima e lui pensa che ti ripensa decide
di fare qualcosa ripeto è a Milano a
questo studio di ematologia e pensa di
fare una cosa anche abbastanza semplice
mette un annuncio su un Corriere della
Sera di quell'epoca
chiedendo a Uomini e Donne disposti di
buona volontà disposti a donare
gratuitamente il proprio sangue nel
frattempo siamo nel 1927 e a questo
appuntamento si presentano in 17 16
uomini e una donna
sono passati degli anni adesso i
volontari dell'Avis sono un milione e
trecentomila in tutta Italia
perché Vittorio
come dire fu spinto a far qualcosa a
cambiare le cose avete citato nel corso
della giornata nel corso della del
pomeriggio
tante citazioni importanti di persone
dotte che hanno cambiato la storia e ve
ne faccio una anch'io le ribellioni si
fondano sulla speranza
è Star Wars non so chi di voi l'ha
riconosciuto Rogue One di Guerre
Stellari Ma Vittorio formentano si
inventò proprio una cosa del genere una
rivoluzione gentile Una ribellione
educata e piano piano decise di cambiare
il mondo o quantomeno decise di cambiare
il sistema attraverso cui veniva
venduto prima Donato poi il sangue in
Italia
non fu facile quelle 17 persone se la
Videro dura perché comunque il mercato
del sangue a pagamento era un mercato
Fiorente e a quell'epoca il sangue era
una risorsa preziosa si pagava a caro
prezzo e quindi ci furono anche molte
vicissitudini legate a questa sua
volontà di cambiare le cose e la storia
di Vittorio formentano la storia fosse
impossibile di Vittoria formentano e
dell'Avis si dipana attraverso la storia
con la s maiuscola dell'Italia
arriva il periodo fascista e tutte le
associazioni vengono sciolte anche
l'Avis viene sciolta e diventa
Associazione Nazionale in tutto ciò
Vittorio formentano comunque riesce in
qualche modo a essere il punto di
riferimento anche durante il periodo
fascista tra quei primi che risposero
c'era il numero 2 della dell'Avis la
tessera numero 2 che era Giorgio
moscadelli lui era un operaio Giorgio
era proprio una persona come dire sempre
pronta ad aiutare gli altri se Vittoria
era la mente Giorgio era il braccio
e quindi la storia si dipana arriva la
Seconda Guerra Mondiale
l'Avis formalmente era a fianco del
regime e però mandava anche il sangue ai
Partigiani Quindi come dire In maniera
assolutamente
universale e fu raccontata anche questa
questa storia di Giorgio e Vittorio che
hanno combattuto insieme e che insieme
sono morti perché sono morti a poca
distanza l'uno dall'altro
nel 1977
moscadelli rispose una telefonata perché
come si organizzavano chiaramente non
c'erano i cellulari Quindi le persone
che donavano il loro sangue
gratuitamente si mettevano a
disposizione mettevano a disposizione il
proprio numero di telefono di casa e una
sorta di orario di reperibilità perché
erano tutte persone che lavoravano la
donazione di sangue è molto nata nei
luoghi di lavoro e Giorgio si sentì
chiamare al telefono dicendo Giorgio
Mi hanno chiamato per per una
trasfusione ma non posso Giorgio perché
quell'uomo è un fascista nel frattempo
c'era stata la fine della guerra e
giorgio gli rispose Prima di tutto è un
malato quindi vai e non è il tuo sangue
e anche questo come dire è importante
oggi perché di fronte alle necessità di
fronte al bisogno non c'è credo non c'è
religione non c'è ideologia politica che
tenga come fece Giorgio a cambiare il
mondo piano piano lui era un ematologo
importante fece anche tante scoperte
mediche contribuì a fondare la feat la
federazione internazionale delle
organizzazioni del dono del sangue che
ancora oggi c'è e opera e che fa
fondamentalmente lobby di tipo buono in
tutti i governi del mondo per come dire
scacciare definitivamente la piaga del
sangue a pagamento e lo sapete In Italia
Quand'è che il sangue a pagamento è
stato definitivamente tolto dal nostro
ordinamento Si parlava del 1927 la legge
che rende l'adazione a pagamento il
legale in Italia del 1990
quindi a Vittorio formentano C'è voluto
un bel popper poter portare avanti la
sua opera non da solo era molto nel 77
ma e noi oggi continuiamo la sua opera e
vi faccio un esempio
non si fa non si dona non si dà il
sangue a pagamento quasi dappertutto
Ormai in nel mondo Ma esiste la d'azione
di plasma a pagamento il plasma siccome
dal plasma si producono plasmade
derivati viene venduto ancora in molte
parti d'Italia del mondo e non solamente
in paesi terzi anche nella civilissima
Austria o nei civilissimi Stati Uniti
per esempio dove gli stabilimenti per
ladazione di plasma a pagamento spesso
sorgono al confine col Messico Proprio
perché le persone che a volte sono più
meno abbienti possano in qualche modo
andare a vendere il loro sangue lo
vendono il loro plasma lo vendono anche
quattro volte a settimana Quindi
immaginatevi come in che condizioni
possono dare il loro plasma peraltro con
la pandemia la produzione di plasma
americana è crollata vertiginosamente
perché durante il lockdown il governo
americano ha dato delle dei sussidi
d'altro tipo e quindi le persone meno
abbienti che vendevano il plasma per
vivere Hanno smesso e c'è stato un
crollo di circa il 20%.
un'altra citazione Dotta No questa è
detta davvero
di Umberto Veronesi dice che le
innovazioni si fondano sulla capacità di
trasgredire Ora noi leghiamo la
trasgressione spesso ha degli
atteggiamenti anche violenti Ecco la
storia fosse impossibile di Vittorio
formentano è proprio quello di essersi
Inventati una forza tranquilla una forza
gentile un coraggio che è andato avanti
nel corso degli anni e per noi è bello
oggi noi siamo vedete fuori c'era il
nostro panchina c'era qui in Lavis
comunale di Siena in qualche modo
testimoniare e portare avanti quella
eredità che Vittorio formentano e
Giorgio Moscatelli ci hanno lasciato e
di cui siamo veramente Fieri quella
eredità che parla appunto di ribellione
di speranza e di trasgressione e di
innovazione Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]